E aí
e em fevereiro de 2020 eu tive uma das
experiências mais extremas da minha vida
eu tive a oportunidade de escalar o
monte Kilimanjaro o monte Kilimanjaro é
a montanha mais alta do continente
africano e uma das montanhas mais altas
do planeta Terra com quase 6 mil metros
de altitude quando voltei da África para
minha casa em São Paulo a minha namorada
da época me fez uma pergunta bastante
curiosa Ela me perguntou Rodrigo qual é
a sensação de chegar no cume do
Kilimanjaro uma das montanhas mais altas
do planeta
Oi E a minha resposta para ela foi a
primeira coisa que me veio à cabeça Olha
a sensação é de que eu tinha chegado na
metade do caminho eu ainda precisava de
ser toda montanha é para quem não
conhece fazer uma expedição escalar uma
alta montanha é realmente uma
experiência que exige muita preparação
não é Como assim sair de casa para fazer
uma trilha de final de semana é a
Expedição do kilimangiaro ela dura sete
dias e durante esse sete dias Você
caminha de 8 a 12 horas por dia todos os
dias então realmente é algo bem intenso
que inclusive envolve risco de vida a
minha preparação para o Kilimanjaro
envolver o CrossFit é um esporte que eu
já era adepto e eu gostava bastante eu
acho que ele dá uma preparação física
bem completa Eu também é pratiquei
bastante yoga no período para
é uma preparação Mental é uma das
Preparações mais importantes que a gente
tem para fazer para essas expedições e
eu fiz um treino de força é um dos
treinos mais simples e fáceis e qualquer
pessoa pode fazer que é simplesmente
pegar uma mochila e encher ela de peso
de livro pesado por exemplo subir e
descer as escadas do seu prédio a alta
montanha e as expedições e montanha Elas
têm muitos Paralelos com o mundo dos
negócios por exemplo para você fazer uma
expedição como essa você precisa ter
Gestão de Risco gestão de recursos você
precisa de planejamento você precisa
lidar com imprevistos você precisa ter
uma boa comunicação e um bom trabalho em
equipe é isso é muito parecido com
empreender com administrar e tocar uma
empresa por isso inclusive que o
montanhismo é a uma das um dos esportes
que eu mais admiro que eu mais gosto de
fazer é
hoje eu quero trazer as três principais
lições que eu aprendi sobre o futuro do
mundo dos negócios ao escalar o
Kilimanjaro com quase 6 mil metros
e setenta por cento dos acidentes em
montanha acontecem na descida
e isso é bastante contraintuitivo e
algumas pessoas ficam surpresas ao saber
disso é na descida que os acidentes com
morte com morte acontecem devido à
extrema exaustão do montanhista muitas
vezes por exemplo a má gestão de
recursos às vezes é o time errado ele
demorou muito para subir a montanha e ao
descer já tá noite ele acaba se perdendo
ou simplesmente porque ele colocou toda
a energia para chegar no cume é essa
inclusive é um é um dos é um dos grandes
Paralelos que eu trago com o mundo dos
negócios eu acredito que no mundo dos
negócios o cume é como se fosse a venda
todo mundo quer chegar lá todo mundo
quer a parte mais pela amorosa da
expedição inteira mas se você não descer
a montanha se você não sobreviver a
descida e guardar energias e se preparar
para aquele momento também você é
simplesmente
a tag subir a próxima montanha a descida
da montanha é como se fosse o pós-vendas
muitas empresas colocam Toda energia em
vender mas não colocam sua energia em
entregar para o seu cliente a primeira
lição portanto que eu trago para o
futuro do mundo dos negócios lá do mundo
do alpinismo e do montanhismo é que o
cume é só a metade do caminho eu não
acredito e empresas que colocam sem por
cento de energia para fazer a venda e
depois simplesmente não entregam ou
simplesmente não presta um bom serviço
para os seus clientes a minha missão EA
missão do meu negócio é potencializar
empresas que cuidam das pessoas não só
dos seus clientes mas também dos seus
parceiros fornecedores e funcionários eu
acredito que o futuro do mundo dos
negócios vai estar repleto de empresas
que realmente se importam
é uma das formas de se fazer gestão de
vendas é utilizando o funil de vendas o
funil de vendas para quem não conhece é
uma representação teórica do que
acontece em qualquer departamento de
vendas para qualquer produto qualquer
serviço qualquer ticket em qualquer
lugar do mundo eu vou explicar um pouco
basicamente lá em cima do Funil é aonde
estão a maior parte das pessoas para
fazer uma venda você precisa falar com
muitas pessoas um pouco menos de pessoas
vai se interessar pela sua proposta um
pouco menos de pessoas ainda vai comprar
o seu produto e o seu serviço eu
acredito que o funil de vendas É sim uma
teoria bastante eficiente para você
gerir o seu negócio mas eu uso a dizer
que ele está ultrapassado
e o funil de vendas ele reforça a ideia
de que o cume é o principal objetivo a
venda é o principal objetivo e eu não
acredito que a venda é o fim de tudo eu
acredito que a venda é o início
e o funil uma [ __ ] é uma versão
atualizado dessa ferramenta de gestão
depois da primeira venda vem as melhores
oportunidades para você fazer negócios
com aquele cliente depois de uma
primeira venda por exemplo pode vir uma
segunda venda depois da primeira venda
você pode vender um produto que o
relacionado você pode vender um produto
de maior ticket você pode reter aquele
cliente ele pode te dar dinheiro por
muito tempo e inclusive você pode
incentivar as indicações desse cliente
uma das estratégias mais inteligentes
que eu acredito por futuro do mundo dos
negócios é quando você cria clientes
vendedores
e eu acredito que o pós-vendas é o novo
vendas ou seja as empresas que focam
apenas em subir a montanha apenas em
fazer a venda e não entregar o seu
produto ou serviço nesse mundo que a
gente tá vivendo um mundo de Hiper é
hiper transparência com redes sociais
com sites de reviews e avaliação em
todos os lugares provavelmente essas
empresas não vão mais existir
e eu não nasci um montanhista eu não
nasci com vontade de escalar montanhas e
até hoje é muito difícil de explicar
para as pessoas as pessoas não entendem
é o porque a gente se submete a um risco
de vida grande é um risco de muitas
vezes congelar um membro do nosso corpo
e ainda paga caro por causa disso a não
ser que você tenha nascido Numa família
de montanhistas Essa não é a realidade
da maioria das pessoas e as empresas de
montanhismo elas sabem disso empresas de
equipamentos roupas ou agências de
viagem por exemplo Elas têm uma
estratégia que é uma das estratégias
mais inteligentes para se criar clientes
essa estratégia é a produção de conteúdo
o meu próprio caso nessa minha história
do clima de aro eu não sabia como que se
fazia para escalar uma montanha eu não
sabia nem por onde começar eu não sabia
como que era o tamanho do desafio mas
e blogs artigos fóruns assistir vídeos
no YouTube no Instagram muitos deles
inclusive produzidos pelas próprias
empresas eu me tornei cliente delas uma
das formas mais inteligentes de você é
trazer novos clientes nesse mundo que a
gente está vivendo é você educar as
pessoas a segunda lição que eu trago do
mundo das montanhas Para o Futuro do
mundo dos negócios é que educar é vender
é a maior parte dos empresários de forma
errada pensa que produzir conteúdo vai
tirar parte do seu mercado tu Rodrigo
porque o meu cliente vai querer comprar
de mim se eu Já ensinei tudo para ele se
ele já sabe como funciona e ele não tem
mais nada para consumir de mim depois
disso é educação faz exatamente o efeito
oposto o efeito inverso quando você
educa o seu cliente o seu cliente agora
sabe que você é especialista naquele
assunto quando você produz conteúdo o
seu cliente ele te coloca na cabeça dele
como um especialista quando ele pensa em
montanha ele vai pensar em você também
muitas pessoas acabam te conhecendo
somente por causa do conteúdo que você
produz eu acredito que atualmente uma
das grandes Barreiras de entrada para se
montar um novo negócio se montar uma
nova empresa é a a atenção da audiência
O resultado é A Grande Barreira de
entrada era o capital precisava de muito
dinheiro para começar um negócio né É e
atualmente é começar uma nova empresa
nunca foi tão fácil o problema é que se
ficou fácil para mim ficou fácil para
você também que está me assistindo ficou
fácil para o nosso vizinho para pessoa
que tá lá no país vizinho ou mesmo no
outro continente portanto ter a atenção
das pessoas é o grande desafio e
produzir conteúdo não só qualquer
conteúdo mas conteúdo de valor é uma das
estratégias mais inteligentes para você
lidar com isso eu acredito que se você
pensar em gerar valor antes de extrair
valor você provavelmente vai ser vai ter
essa balança muito bem equilibrada
dentro do seu negócio dentro da sua
empresa
em todas essas estratégias elas não
funcionam se você não tiver uma coisa e
essa coisa é o propósito a Rodrigo
propósito de novo esse é um assunto
muito Clichê O que que tem de novidade
em cima disso bom eu vou te dar o meu
exemplo sobre propósito Eu acredito que
empresas existem para gerar qualidade de
vida para as pessoas eu não acredito que
no futuro do mundo dos negócios vão
continuar existindo empresas que extraem
qualidade de vida das pessoas e Que
pessoas são essas essas pessoas são os
nossos clientes essas pessoas são os
nossos funcionários E essas pessoas
inclusive são os nossos parceiros e os
nossos fornecedores Como eu disse é uma
empresa que faz vendas mas não entrega
para aquele cliente está assim tirando
qualidade de vida daquela pessoa essa
empresa vai deixar de existir
o outro exemplo empresas que o
funcionário entra começa a trabalhar e
sei lá fica obeso depressivo com
gastrite é essa pessoa também ela tá é
perdendo qualidade de vida e eu não
acredito que essa empresa vai continuar
existindo no futuro do mundo dos
negócios e mesmo aquela empresa que
extrai o seu fornecedor né aí negocia
até o último centavo essa empresa também
está tirando qualidade de vida né lá do
seu fornecedor provavelmente essas
empresas não vão continuar existindo no
futuro do mundo dos negócios a terceira
lição que eu trago das montanhas para o
mundo dos negócios é que as pessoas elas
não compram só um produto no serviço mas
elas também compram quem você é e o que
você faz
Há muitos consumidores têm cada vez mais
olhando para isso na hora de tomar suas
decisões de compra e na montanha
acontece da mesma forma o pensamento
mais recorrente que passa pela cabeça de
um alpinista é eu vou desistir Será que
isso vale a pena porque que eu vim para
aqui o que que eu tô fazendo mas é só
por causa de um propósito Claro cada um
tem o seu e o meu é explorar locais que
poucas pessoas visitaram que a gente
continua a gente segue firme respira e
vai até o objetivo final
e tem uma última História que eu quero
contar sobre a minha expedição no
Kilimanjaro é o Kilimanjaro fica na
Tanzânia e na Tanzânia o idioma oficial
é o suaíli e sua really é um idioma é
falado por poucas pessoas basicamente só
na Tanzânia mas existem duas expressões
lá que são muito conhecidas e muito
utilizadas a primeira expressão é o
hakuna matata hakuna matata para quem é
fã do Rei Leão sabe que significa sem
problemas Fique tranquilo e a segunda
expressão bastante utilizada lá no país
é o poli poli poli poli não tem uma
tradução as indireta para o português
mas significaria alguma coisa como siga
em frente ou uma coisa por vez ou ainda
direção é mais importante do que a
velocidade
e no dia do ataque ao cume que é o
último dia de expedição último Sprint
final quando a gente sai do Acampamento
Até chegar na montanha Aconteceu algo
que eu nunca vou esquecer a gente sai do
Acampamento aproximadamente à meia-noite
a gente chega no cume da montanha pelas
sete horas da manhã e o plano é chegar
no acampamento de volta até às 15horas
se faz isso por uma questão de segurança
para que a gente possa mesmo tendo algum
problema no meio do caminho voltar ainda
enquanto é dia ir lá pelas 3 e 6 ou 4
horas da manhã quase é um grupo de
alemães Passou por nós voando montanha
cima muito rápido
e Eu reconheci que eles eram alemães
porque eu falo um pouco de alemão quando
criança eu estudei em colégio alemão eu
até troquei uma ideia com eles lá na
hora foi bem curioso bem divertido e um
desses alemães utilizavam uma bota muito
clássica no alpinismo quero uma bota
amarela quando eles passaram por nós eu
chamei o meu guia e disse Pô cara eu tô
bem será que a gente consegue acelerar
um pouco passo será que a gente consegue
acompanhar um pouco os alemães e o meu
guia é só olhou para mim e disse Rodrigo
direção é mais importante que velocidade
polypore e assim a gente seguiu ali
naquele passo de um passo para cada
inspiração e expiração outro passo para
cada inspiração e expiração
e antes de chegar no cume da montanha
existe um lugar que se chama Dilma
expoente que é um ponto clássico de
descanso lá no Kilimanjaro porque ele é
menos inclinados o que a parede da
montanha e quando eu cheguei lá para
minha surpresa eu encontrei o alemão o
Alemão tava deitado numa situação
deplorável ele tava com uma cara muito
muito ruim ele tá lá aparentemente
exausto deitado assim encostado numa
pedra Eu reconheci ele por causa da bota
amarela dele e eu acenei para ele ele
acenou para mim eu vi que ele ainda
tinha condições ali né decidiu o que
fazer descer a montanha e seguir o meu
caminho para o cume da montanha
Olá pessoal eu não encontrei o Alemão no
cume da montanha eu tenho um pouco
encontrei o alemão na descida da
montanha e provavelmente ele nunca tenha
conseguido chegar no objetivo isso
porque ele colocou todas as suas
energias na subida e não se preocupa
também com a descida se você nesse
momento se encontra nessa situação e
empreendendo começando um negócio e as
coisas parecem não dar certo fique
tranquilo lembre-se não coloque toda sua
energia tentando ali fazer a sua
primeira venda afinal de contas o cume é
só metade do caminho e empreender e
tocar um grande negócio tocar uma
empresa é como fazer uma expedição para
alta montanha é ardo é trabalhoso é
penoso vai ser cansativo mas lembre-se
sempre direção é mais importante do que
velocidade lembre-se do seu propósito
ele que vai
a seguir à frente Polly Polly e muito
obrigado a